[Music]
since 2016 we've known the rather
unconventional but at least as popular
superhero deadpool
needless to say the two movies released
so far have been full of action loot
comments and brute force
and have thus been able to build up a
stable fan base now
everyone is even more excited about the
third part as
expectations couldn't be higher in
today's original we tell you all you
need to know about the upcoming deadpool
3
so lean back and enjoy
the first thing on the list is obviously
the story of the upcoming movie
but before we get started let's take a
quick look at the past two parts so as
to refresh our memory bit
the story revolves around former special
forces agent wade wilson who now works
as a mercenary
sadly at the beginning of the first part
he falls terminally ill with cancer
and sees a daring experiment as a last
resort to escape death
however he did not take into account the
cruel ajax who unscrupulously pushes his
subjects to the extreme in order to give
them super powers
for weight the procedure seems to work
as well and henceforth he's capable of
healing his body much faster than his
human fellow citizens
all being at the price of a completely
disfigured body
clearly the vein weight cannot go out in
public like this which is why in
addition to his alter ego deadpool
he also acquires a matching red and
black superhero suit
thankfully he hasn't lost his biting
sense of humor so together with the
x-men mutants negasonic teenage warhead
and colossus
he plots an unprecedented vendetta
against ajax
while also trying to save his girlfriend
vanessa the second part from 2018
more or less picks up at the end of the
first part ajax has been killed
and vanessa is in safe hands for now our
favorite loudmouth has meanwhile come to
terms with the situation
though he barely has time to catch his
breath deadpool who is now working as a
hitman
is found at home by a dragonlord
following an aborted mission and is
forced to watch as his beloved vanessa
is shot dead having found support among
the x-men
he makes it his duty to protect the
young mutant russell alias firefist from
the villain cable
on his own however he doesn't stand a
chance which is why he establishes the
x-force
a strike force made up of normal mortals
as well as mutants
after the near death of deadpool and the
turbulent end of the second part
the desire for another film was
naturally awakened
what is known about the third part
anyway unfortunately not as much as we
would like to know
lead actor ryan reynolds has often
emphasized in the past that the third
movie will take a completely new
direction
and that many movies make the mistake of
developing their main character far too
late
might this be a small hint that deadpool
will make his first appearance under the
mcu or marvel brand after the fox
takeover
well there's at least no need to worry
about the age rating as marvel boss
kevin foggy has no plans to make the new
film
less brutal than his two predecessors
after all the franchise remains
almost inseparable from an rating in
fact screenwriter paul vernick devolves
to the website den of geek the deadpool
3 could become very crossover heavy
referring perhaps to the x-men or
fantastic four just to name a few
as you can see the fox takeover has made
many things somewhat unclear
nevertheless we don't want to keep one
of ryan reynolds ideas from you
originally deadpool 3 was supposed to be
a joint road movie with wolverine
similar to our kirakura sava's classic
roshamon the narrative threats would
then differ according to the character
and would sort of tell their very own
story regardless
this plan has been scrapped and there's
still no valid clues about the story of
part 3.
so what are your thoughts what will the
ideal storyline for a third part look
like
new characters increased violence or
perhaps more satire
feel free to let us know in the comments
we'll now present a few interesting
stories from the countless deadpool
comics
as well as an idea of our own which we
can imagine quite well in the third part
some of them may seem rather absurd by
the standards of a modern blockbuster
but then again we're talking about
deadpool here
first let's talk about the 2012 comic
deadpool kills the marvel universe
the plot corresponds to a classic
revenge story in which deadpool turns to
an even more disturbed maniac than he
already is
the focus here is less on charming
sayings and more on badass violence
the target of his rampage are the
well-known mcu greats with deadpool even
killing spider-man with a headshot
is this too harsh or might this even be
the thematic twist ryan reynolds is
talking about
along similar lines is the fairly recent
2018 comic black panther vs deadpool
in which as the name suggests the red
and black mercenary sets up for wakanda
to obtain the much sought after
vibranium to save a fantastic four
mailman
of course king t'challa can think of a
thousand other uses for the vibranium
and so he refuses to hand it over to
deadpool
meanwhile t'challa finds out that wade
doesn't have any healing abilities at
all
and that he's merely a walking tumor in
the end in order to defeat the
supervillain jack-o-lantern who's also
heading to wakanda
the two of them joined forces in
addition to the two comics
we can imagine another interesting story
for deadpool 3.
in line with a multiverse hype that has
been dominating the movie scene lately
a kind of deadpool into the deadpool
verse would be pretty exciting
how fun would it be to have multiple
deadpools clashed to wreak havoc
together
or perhaps even go for each other's
throats maybe there's
an evil deadpool a good deadpool a tiny
bit
a female deadpool and so forth all
meeting through some curious universe or
time shift
after all we already know about the time
travel from the second part so why not
jump on the multiverse bandwagon
sure this is all pure speculation but we
can definitely imagine a similar
storyline
information on the cast is also still
scarce
it is true that deadpool 3 has been in
production since the end of 2020 but
official news is
still being kept under wraps the x-force
characters
if they haven't died in part two anyway
won't all be back
well at least the character domino won't
since actress zazie beats spoke out
about it last march
revealing that she would be happy to
assume the roll again but
hasn't been contacted or told anything
about it more likely is the return of
stefan kaepechek as colossus
brianna hildebrand as negasonic teenage
warhead
shioli katsuna as yukio julian dennis
ness russell
and of course marina baccarin as vanessa
but once again we can do nothing but
guess
the actually deceased shadowstar in
zeitgeist could also be making a return
after all
anything is possible in superhero movies
involving time machines
though we shouldn't get too carried away
speculating at this point
behind the camera things look a bit more
subtle with bob's burgers writer andy
and lizzy molyneux said to be providing
that certain
something in the script according to a
report from deadline the two were chosen
after they sat down with reynolds and
managed to convince him
also clear is that deadpool 3 will
definitely not be shot this year after
all ryan reynolds is one of the biggest
and most popular actors in hollywood
and they're not exactly known for having
a laid-back schedule thus a release
before 2023 is considered
highly unlikely anyhow the best way to
get news is through reynold's social
media posts where the 44 year old keeps
publishing little teasers as well as
easter eggs
well that's it again with our latest
episode we hope that despite this still
really poor news
we were able to offer you a little
insight into the current state of
affairs
let us hear your theories and
speculations about deadpool 3 in the
comment section and discuss them
if you also enjoyed the video we would
obviously appreciate it if you like and
subscribe
see you next time
[Music]
you